our exalted experts want to hold us
prisoner to coronavirus for another 18
months while prosecutors dish out felony
charges to formerly free Americans who
have the goal to go outside for a walk
we will examine the junk science behind
the most outrageous political power grab
of our lifetime then China infiltrates a
White House press briefing President
Trump threatens to cut funding to the
World Health Organization and Joe Biden
steps up and addresses the nation about
his weakness for Fig Newtons all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
they want to keep us locked up forever
that's it
initially it was 15 days to stop the
spread then it was going to be another
two weeks after that so what no I'm
sorry another 30 days after that so it's
gonna be 45 days total now they're
saying maybe another month now they're
saying maybe another month and Zeke
Emanuel Aria Manuel's brother Rahm
Emmanuel's brother one of the architects
of Obamacare says that we could be
locked up for another 18 months while we
wait for a vaccine for the corona virus
you know even the rosy numbers coming
out of the White House we hear from
Larry Kudlow he's saying it could be
another four to eight weeks very
different than 15 days forty-five plus
eight weeks that's a lot of time but
that's the rosiest number now we're
hearing it could be as much as 18 months
here is that Obamacare architect telling
us why we've got to all hunker down for
a year and a half realistically kovat 19
will be here for the next 18 months or
more we will not be able to return to
normalcy until we find a vaccine or
effective medications I know that's
dreadful news to hear how are people
supposed to find work if this goes on in
some form for a year and a half is all
that economic pain worth trying to stop
Kovan 19 the truth is we have no choice
if we prematurely end that physical
distancing and the other measures
keeping it at bay deaths could skyrocket
into the hundreds of thousands if not a
million we cannot return to normal until
there's a vaccine conferences concerts
sporting events religious services
dinner in a restaurant none of that will
resume until we find a vaccine a
treatment or a cure oh oh is that so dr.
Emmanuel well alright then in that case
I respectfully how about you go stuff it
guy all right stop stop it stop telling
us based on faulty models that we can't
do anything that we want to do and we've
got to listen to you and do exactly what
you say if these guys had been right
from the beginning
and they would have a lot of credibility
now all right I'm not saying that we
have to be against quarantine spur say
I'm not saying that we can't suffer
economic hardship if there's an epidemic
the trouble is these guys have been
wrong from the very beginning okay and
we cannot be shut down and locked up
inside of our apartments under threat of
prosecution for 18 months just can't
happen
why for four reasons as far as I can see
it first of all we cannot afford it we
were locked down for what two or three
weeks and in order to deal with that the
Congress had to pass the largest
stimulus measure ever we needed to come
up with six trillion dollars in relief
two trillion passed by Congress and
other four trillion levered up by the
Fed just to get us through a few weeks
how much money are we gonna need to
spend for 18 months we could probably
buy the green New Deal two or three
times if we were to get through all of
that which of course we cannot cuz
that's not how economies work and we'll
have a little more on that later on
second reason that won't work
the models have been wrong and this
point I cannot harp on it enough we were
told time and time again two million
Americans are gonna die right or more
than two million Americans may be from
coronavirus we were told even if we
follow all the great measures and the
social distancing and wear the masks
we're still looking at what half a
million few hundred thousand at least if
not half a million if not a million
those were the more modest estimates how
does that compare with reality right now
at what we are being told is the peak of
the virus more Americans died from swine
flu under Barack Obama than have died so
far from the coronavirus now look that
number is going to change we're if even
if we are peaking and we're on the down
side of the slope that's still a lot
more misery to go through but right now
today at the peak more people died from
swine o.9 than have died so far from Co
vid 19 so let's say the number right now
is about 1213 thousand let's say the
number gets up to 30
or 40,000 or 50,000 or a hundred
thousand even those are numbers that are
similar to the number of deaths we see
each year from drug overdoses and who
knows how the drug overdose deaths are
going to be affected by this when
there's economic collapse guess what
goes right through the roof drug
overdose deaths and suicides so the very
people who sold us the bogus models are
the ones telling us that we now need to
remain locked up for a year and a half
why else can't we handle this two very
important reasons the last one is the
one that nobody's talking about we'll
get to that in a second first I have got
to thank our advertisers you know right
now little economic difficulty going on
and I know that a lot of people are
having trouble in their businesses that
includes our advertisers so I want to
thank so much the advertising partners
who are sticking around and and not
panicking in the economic turmoil it
really helps us so much we really really
appreciate it
you know we also appreciate it when our
listeners go out and help those sponsors
who keep us on the air and one of my
absolute favorite sponsors ever is paint
your life you know one thing I've been
doing at now that I've been at home a
little bit more is I've taken up
painting turns out painting is much more
difficult than it looks there's that I'm
not the world-class artist perhaps not
yet at least but you know who are the
painters have paint your life and right
now
you can get a wonderful painting made
from you upload a photograph you get a
world-class artist to paint it for you I
got a beautiful oil painting you can get
that right now through paint your life
and don't forget Mother's Day is coming
up if you're looking for a way to feel
connected to loved ones when you can't
be near then you've got to try paint
your life calm this service is so
unbelievable I got one for my
step-brother for his wedding that it's
just absolutely gorgeous I've
recommended this to all of my friends
and now that I'm trying to be an amateur
painter I have even more respect for
their wonderful artists paint your life
calm there's no risk if you don't love
the final painting you your money is
refunded you're working them the whole
with them the whole time that's
guaranteed right now is a limited time
for get 20% off your painting 20% off
and free shipping
text the word Michel mi CH AE l to
64,000 that is Michael to 64,000 texts
Michael to 64,000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
alright so first two reasons that we
can't remain lockdown for 18 months we
cannot afford it and the models have
been totally wrong third reason is we
have medicines and treatments for
coronaviruses Zeke Emanuel said we can't
reopen until we have medicine and
treatment for coronavirus I think we do
we have multiple medicines that are in
the works I mean probably most notably
hydroxychloroquine which the left by the
way is still trying to cover up we'll
get to that in just a little bit because
the New York Times is behaving even more
egregiously than usual when it comes to
this drug that has shown great promise
at treating coronavirus so do we have a
vaccine yet no but a vaccine could take
18 months and until we have a vaccine we
have a drug that has been shown time and
time again so many doctors we've played
a number of them on this show who say
that that drug is working so we check
that box and yet this expert still wants
to drag it on 18 months the fourth and
final and most important reason that we
cannot lock down for 18 months more is
that this is the most insane political
power grab that we have seen in our
lifetimes ever okay you want to you want
a great example of this I read this
story yesterday at a Cincinnati a
Hamilton County Prosecutor Joe deters is
now not only ordering people to stay at
home he's now saying that if you go out
go for a walk
violate your stay at home order you will
be arrested you will be charged with a
felony you can quote sit your butt in
jail you can sit there and kill yourself
I don't care but you're not going to
kill my kids and you're not gonna kill
my neighbors kids I'm done with this
nonsense so we'll see what happens this
lunatic who by the way is wrong on the
facts because the grown
virus has not been shown to infect
children just about anywhere so the
safest people from gorona virus are
children complete demagoguery on his
part but what he is saying is that if
you a free American have the gall the
audacity to walk outside you will be
arrested charged with a felony you can
sit in jail and kill yourself
yeah you can go sit in jail and kill
yourself because otherwise you might
kill people otherwise people might die
at the same time as government officials
around the country or releasing violent
criminals in New York and in jail they
released child rapists because they
didn't want the jails to be overcrowded
this schmuck is arresting people
charging them with felonies throwing
them in jails for going for a walk he
says I told the chief to charge him with
felonious assault I don't care this is
going to stop I'm telling you at least
now the guy is going to stop now he got
even more specific cause you think okay
well maybe people don't need to go to
bars or clubs or things like that not
that they're open but surely there's got
to be some exception right there's gonna
be some exception for say if you go to
church right
no actually Joe deters says if I was the
governor I would tell these churches the
first attendees at your church is going
to be the National Guard because we are
stopping this right now okay we're
stopping it no one is asking you not to
pray to God no one is asking you not to
pray to Allah no one is asking you not
to pray it can be done remotely it's not
a problem but if it applies to these
kids and over-the-rhine it should apply
to those churches too and they need to
just stop it so first of all just on a
theological point he's wrong okay for
certain denominations and certain
religious groups you can just do it at
home it doesn't matter if you go to
church for churches that recognize the
sacraments most notably the Catholic
Church but Protestant denominations too
you do have to go to church you can't
just do it from home forever
it does matter that you're in person so
a very ignorant statement and not only
is it ignorant of the religion it's
ignorant of our tradition of religious
liberty and Liberty generally in the
United States this
lunatic has gotten drunk with power
here are some examples he the police had
the police arrest
rashon Davis this guy who decided to
walk outside had the police just arrest
him charge him with a felony he's it's
not just a big talk with this guy Joe
deters it's it's actually happening you
had - and you know it's - I looked up
this guy Joe Deiters he's actually had a
pretty good career
he's got mostly conservative political
positions he's been around a long time
right it's not as though he's some
deranged left-winger what's so scary
about this power grab is that it's
corrupting even conservatives even
right-wingers it's corrupting people in
government because they are stealing
absurd unprecedented power in many cases
and something tells me they're not gonna
want to give it back quite so easily the
point is this shutdown is not without
consequence okay there are many hidden
costs - the quarantine not just to our
economy but to our government not just
to our government but our way of life to
our politics and not the least of all -
lives there are consequences to lives of
the quarantine people will die
because some demagogues and experts and
politicians are trying to save people
Andy Cuomo in New York he said if
everything we do saves just one life it
will have been worth it let's take a
look at just one effect of this alarmism
and this quarantine in this hysteria to
see if it's worth it this story takes
place in Illinois there is a man living
with his girlfriend
the man is paranoid he's afraid that his
girlfriend has the coronavirus so she
goes she gets tested for the corona
virus she comes back before they get the
test results the man kills his
girlfriend and kills himself this is
according to the sheriff's office in wil
County Illinois murder suicide because
he was so if
of getting the coronavirus what are the
circumstances of this was he afraid that
she would give it to him was he afraid
that they would both have it and die in
misery was he completely ignorant of the
statistics and the reality of this virus
maybe because it was so hyped up by
demagogues in the media and in politics
yeah I don't know all I know is we got
two bodies now lying on the ground
because of the alarmism so look I don't
do this kind of utilitarian math but
handy formal apparently does so you got
the one life that you've saved from the
coronavirus now you got two body bags
from the alarmism how do you do that
calculation how do you make that
together if we save one life it was all
worth it was it worth it does the Andrew
Cuomo still think that it was worth it
this is not just a one random case in
Illinois all right I expose it is a
random case it's not just a standalone
though because we know when there are
economic downturns suicide goes up we
know as we said earlier drug abuse goes
up we know that people die in this
situation so was it worth it by the way
we don't even really know how many
people have died from the virus even the
official count we don't know we'll get
to why that isn't a second because dr.
Burks at the White House just confirmed
that for us yesterday first I've got to
thank our friends over at quit you know
when you're stuck at home it's very easy
to let certain basic habits like oral
hygiene fall by the wayside that is
exactly why you need to go get a great
toothbrush and stick to your healthy
habits okay I have sworn by an electric
toothbrush for years you should too
good habits mean brushing for two
minutes twice a day flossing regularly
no matter what brand you use quip makes
that simple starting with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and anti
cavity toothpaste quips electric brush
has sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
get a full and even clean the flip flops
dispenser comes with pre marked string
to help you use just exactly enough plus
quip delivers fresh brush heads floss
and toothpaste refills to your door
every three months with free shipping so
you don't forget your routine as always
right
the three million healthy mouths and get
quipped today starting of 25 bucks if
you go to get quip comm slash Michael
right now you'll get your first refill
free that is your first refill free at
get quip calm slash Michael that is
spelled GE t qu IP comm slash mi CH AE L
quip the good habits company so even if
we were gonna try to do this and equal
no kind of math where you save one life
and it's all worth it but what about if
you lose one life on the other side even
if we were going to do that we don't
know how many people have died from the
corona virus that's according to dr.
Burks yesterday at the White House we
know that now because she told us that
deaths from coronavirus are being
recorded in her words in the most
liberal way possible so in other words
if anybody dies with the corona virus
then they are going to be recorded as
dying from the corona virus so I think
in this country we've taken a very
liberal approach to mortality and I
think the reporting here has been pretty
straightforward over the last five to
six weeks prior to that when there
wasn't testing in January and February
that's a very different situation and
unknown there are other countries that
if you had a pre-existing condition and
let's say the virus called you to go to
the ICU and then have a heart or kidney
problem some countries are recording
that as a heart issue or a kidney issue
and not a Kovan 19 death right now we're
still recording it and we all I mean the
great thing about having forms that come
in and a form that has the ability to
mark it as covert 19 infection the
intent is right now that those if
someone dies with Kovan 19 we are
counting that as a copan 19 death
all right this makes a huge difference
it might not seem like it does because
you say well look I'm sure the the kovat
19 didn't help the condition sure but it
makes a huge difference
according to the New York City Data
65.5% of New Yorkers who have died from
coronavirus had at least one
pre-existing condition and these
pre-existing conditions usually are
pretty serious specifically we're
talking about diabetes lung disease
cancer immunodeficiency heart disease
hypertension asthma kidney disease and
Gi liver disease they had at least one
of them now 65 65.5% that's pretty high
another 30 2.6 percent of New Yorkers
who have died still have pre-existing
conditions pending we don't know whether
or not they had pre-existing conditions
do you know how many people who died of
Kovac 19 in New York were confirmed not
to have pre-existing conditions 1.9
percent just 1.9 percent as of yesterday
that's 46 people look that's still scary
if 46 people who were otherwise healthy
drop dead because of a pandemic that was
started in China that came here and took
us all by surprise that's a scary number
but it's a very different number then if
thousands of people in New York are
dying from that right this is not to say
that some lives are more valuable than
others this is not to say that we should
throw the old and the frail off a cliff
what this tells us though is how
virulent the disease is and if the
virulence of the disease matches what
we're being told in the media if
somebody with stage 4 pancreatic cancer
who does not have a good prognosis
who's got weeks maybe a month or two to
live contracts coronavirus and dies in
the hospital do we really believe that
that death is caused primarily by the
corona virus no of course nobody does
but because of the liberal way to use
dr. Burke's terms that the deaths are
being recorded we will not know those
numbers so it will if anything inflate
the numbers and it could inflate the
numbers of coronavirus deaths pretty
significantly why are they doing it why
record the deaths this way we saw this
kind of recording in Italy we haven't
seen it in a lot of other places this
method of recording the data gives a lot
of cover to politicians give us a lot of
cover to alarmists who have shut down
the global economy because two million
Americans are going to die and then now
it looks pretty clear that two million
Americans are not going to die 1 million
Americans are not going to die it number
could be significantly lower an order of
magnitude lower or even more so this
method of recording seems to have a lot
more to do with politics than it does
with medical science it seems to me that
the more good news we get about this
pandemic the more the media wants to
shut that up the more hysterical the
media wants to become the more alarmist
the media want to be to try to prove
that they were right all along
best example of this is the medicine
that has been treating coronavirus there
are lots of different medicines out
there that might be useful for
coronavirus or a lot being tested right
now but the one that all come always
comes to mind is hydroxychloroquine that
is the drug that was touted by medical
doctors by initially some in the media
by Governor Andrew Cuomo in New York and
by President Trump hydroxychloroquine
has just been shown to be very effective
and the reason it's so helpful is
because it's already been approved by
the FDA for malaria it's a drug that we
have a lot of it's cheap we can produce
quickly and we know that it doesn't kill
you because it's it's been safe to use
for other diseases like malaria like
lupus others as well so the New York
Times is furious about this because how
are they going to raise the alarm bells
how is this going to be this massive
unprecedented endless pandemic if we've
got a medicine for it so the New York
Times is taking every shot they can you
know they've been going after him for
hydroxychloroquine now for weeks they've
been trying to get him to shut up about
this drug so the headline yesterday if
for New York Times reporters on this
peter baker katie rogers david enrich
and Maggie Haberman Maggie Haberman
Hillary Clinton's favorite journalist
headline is Trump's aggressive advocacy
of
Lari a drug for treating coronavirus
divides medical community divides them
huh well I think the doctors who want to
help their patients don't seem divided
on it they seem to be prescribing the
drug I don't know maybe they count
themselves in the New York Times as part
of the medical community maybe they they
count narrative doctors or doctors of
narrative medicine like the person who
wrote in The New York Times yesterday
maybe that's that's who's divided on
this but the real doctors don't seem
divided so that the article doesn't even
spend too much time on the efficacy of
the drug the real political hit job in
this essay is trying to suggest that
President Trump has corrupt motives for
promoting the drug so they say some
Associates of mr. Trump's have financial
interests in the issue
Sanofi is largest shareholders include
Fisher asset management the investment
company run by Ken Fisher a major donor
to Republicans including mr. Trump a
spokesman for mr. Fisher declined to
comment
so what's notable here is they've tried
to tie hydroxychloroquine to Donald
Trump but they can't do it very well so
they say yeah he's got a little bit of a
stake in a company that has a stake in a
company that has a stake in a company in
hydroxychloroquine so they realized
their their better attack is going to be
to go after Trump's friends so if
Trump's friends have any investment in a
company that invests in a company that
invests in a company that ever once
invested in hydroxychloroquine then
they're gonna say this is corruption as
of last year mr. Trump reported that his
three family trusts each had investments
in a Dodge and Cox mutual fund whose
largest holding was in Sanofi Sanofi is
this company that I guess produces
hydroxychloroquine except Ashley Ashley
cause the Sanofi spokeswoman said that
the company no longer sells or
distributes placa nil which is the brand
name of hydroxychloroquine in the United
States although it does not sell it
internationally so or although it does
sell it internationally so they're
saying okay so Trump has some investment
in a mutual fund that invests in this
company Sanofi which used to distribute
a drug called placa nil which is the
brand name of hydroxychloroquine in the
united states but they don't distribute
any more so basically it's total
corruption and he's just trying to fill
his pockets then they go on they say
several generic drug makers are gearing
up to produce hydroxychloroquine pills
including M Neill pharmaceutics whose
co-founder Chirag Patel is a member of
trump National Golf Course Bedminster in
new jersey oh my goodness oh my goodness
so they can't really I mean look anybody
who has a 401k invests in some company
that invested in some company that maybe
has some drug you don't even know what's
in your portfolio so they know that
that's not going to stick on Trump so
now they're saying that there are other
companies that are working on this drug
which by the way undercuts their first
argument because the first argument is
Trump's cornering the market right he's
gonna fill his pockets with this drug if
other companies are producing it that
he's not filling his pockets but the
other companies are producing it they're
saying this is corrupt because one of
the companies that's working on it has
an investment by a company by an
investor by a fund and one of the people
who invests in this is a member of one
of the Trump golf clubs if that if that
is the best they've got
they need to just shut down the New York
Times right now look at all these words
look at all that look at long this
article is oh my gosh it's so long to
tell you that bombshell that a member of
one of trumps golf clubs has an
investment in a fund that invests in a
company that isn't right now producing
all the hydroxychloroquine but maybe
maybe will eventually and then I looked
this was even more fun I looked to see
how much money Trump had invested
because this thing was blowing up Joe
Scarborough tweeted about it
Seth Abramson at Newsweek tweeted about
it Kyle Griffin MSNBC News producer
tweeted out this New York Times article
Aaron Rupe are from voxcom serious
investigative journalists they're all
tweeting about it by the way even George
Conway Kellyanne Conway's husband who is
a major Trump critic even he admitted
this was pretty weak but you had all the
hacks we're tweeting about it so
look I wanted to see how much money
Trump had invested in hydroxychloroquine
take a guess
Donald Trump billionaire very wealthy
man how much money do you think he
invested in hydroxychloroquine if you
look at the percentage of his investment
in the fund and the fund and the company
in the drug so Trump's investment in the
company
that produces hydroxychloroquine or that
doesn't currently in the United States
but used to is at most one thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars that's
how he's getting rich that's it he's
using a pandemic to promote a company
that used to promote this drug they used
to produce this drug that's going to be
used so that he can turn his 1,350
dollar investment into a two thousand
dollar investment it gets better than
that that because we don't know exactly
how much of the company he could own
that's the highest amount at the lower
end the investment could be worth as
little as $90 he's gonna that's it he's
gonna use a global pandemic to bring his
ninety dollar investment up to 120
dollars he's gonna make a cool 30 bucks
and then he's gonna treat everybody to
ice cream afterwards at the White House
it's so so pathetic so that attack
failed spectacularly from the New York
Times so when that failed the press
decided to attack him for possible
negative health consequences from the
medicine and Trump did something very
wise here he didn't just go after the
media on the facts he went after the
media on the narrative and that's the
thing we're all gonna have to do if we
don't want to keep ourselves locked up
for the next 18 months we'll get to that
in a second first I have got to thank
all of you all of you daily wire members
and all access members you know if you
haven't checked out the all-access live
show over a daily wire.com you're
missing out this is the new Members Only
program where I been
Jeremy drew Matt Walsh where we all sit
down on different nights and we just
kind of hang out turn the camera on it's
not even really a show I think of it as
just hanging out it's like a conference
call or a happy hour I consider it a
happy hour because
and I'm drinking during those shows so
definitely go check it out
it's a very fun and initially this was
just for our all-access Live member
there are all access members now we're
opening it up to all of our members
during quarantine which is probably in a
bankrupt us if this quarantine goes on
18 months so it's going live at 5 p.m.
Pacific 8 p.m. Eastern at daly wire.com
I check it out head on over to daily
wire comm if you're not a member already
go to daily wire.com slash subscribe
we'll be right back with a lot more
so when the media can't nail Trump for
the corruption of investing $90 in
hydroxychloroquine they are going after
the health effects of hydroxychloroquine
itself so it at Trump's daily press
briefing where he's his own press
secretary they asked him about this
yesterday about by the side effects
about how we we shouldn't be so quick to
administer this drug to dying patients
here is the reporter with millions of
pills of hydroxychloroquine donated is
there a plan or system in place to track
the potential side-effects
representative serious side-effects the
side-effects are the least of it yet
people dying all over the place so you
know that this is already gonna be some
unfair questioning because she gets the
question out hey are you guys tracking
the side effects of this drug and then
president from starts to answer and she
keeps interrupting him and the side
effects and the side effects and they're
gonna be all these side effects is
they're so upset they're so crestfallen
that the drug is working they're so
upset that people are getting better
because net then it can't be Trump's
fault and Trump can't be responsible for
killing a million people gratz ah they
were sure they were gonna get him this
time the Russia thing didn't work and
the taxes didn't work and the Ukraine
thing remember that they pitched him
over Ukraine in a phone call that didn't
work but they're gonna get him he's
gonna kill a million people then we'll
really get him drats foiled again
because he's promoting a drug that's
working so now they've all they've got
left is they so what about the side
effects and President Trump gives what I
think is the perfect answer to it he
gives the answer not merely in
scientific and medical terms but in
narrative terms a woman last night I
watched her on one of the shows good
show Laura and she was she thought she
was dead
she was a representative from Michigan
she was just in horrible shape for 12
days 14 days she thought she was dead I
think she said that her doctor said
she's you know it's going to be very
tough she saw me talking about this and
she asked her husband to go
the drugs too now this is a Democrat
representative a person that you know
perhaps wouldn't be voting for me I
think she'll be voting for me now even
if she's a Democrat even if she's a
Democrat representative he gave it to
her now you know it's I don't say it
works like this at all four hours later
she awoke and she said I feel better and
then shortly thereafter she felt great
there's a woman that thought she was
gonna die her manner of speaking her the
way she told the story was beautiful I
asked my husband to go and get it he got
it she is now okay so he goes on but I
think you get the point
president Trump is flipping the left's
narrative on them the the left's
narrative this whole time from Andy
Cuomo to Zeke Emanuel to the experts to
the media to the politicians if you
oppose them you want people to die
that's what they're saying if you if you
even so much as question what they're
doing you want people to die view oppose
shutting down the global economy you
want people to die if you oppose
arresting people for leaving their homes
you want people to die now they've gone
even further they say if you support
giving people access to the medicine
that'll save their lives you want people
to die because of hypothetical
side-effects or something that don't
even exist I was and or New York Times
right just yesterday was talking about
how if you support giving people this
medicine you want other people to die
because there is a hypothetical shortage
of the medicine for people who have
lupus even though there's no evidence of
that shortage at all none of that is
true but that is the narrative they're
pushing out so Donald Trump master of
narrative flips the narrative on its
head he says if you oppose giving people
this drug then you want people to die
and he picked probably the perfect
character to destroy the left wings
narrative here because we're talking
about a democratic politician this is a
democratic representative who was on
a death's door and then takes the drug
and now is all better not just a
democratic representative a woman not
just a democratic woman a democratic
black woman I mean it checks every
intersectional box that the left talks
about all the time with identity
politics so now Trump is saying if you
oppose give giving people as medicine
you want a black female democratic
politician to die and I won't let that
happen not on my watch this is the right
attitude this is how we've got to start
speaking we like to play by all the
proper rules Marquess of Queensbury
rules totally fair aboveboard no punches
below the belt the left punches below
the belt the left demagogues the left
emotionally manipulates now we should be
better than the left but we've got to be
able to counter their narratives as well
Trump showed us great way how to do that
he was pretty brutal in this press
briefing all around this is one of the
hallmarks of it you see these these
motifs coming back and all the press
briefings he'll talk about the Cure and
the drug and giving people some hope
he'll talk about how serious it is so we
can't just reopen tomorrow he'll then
humiliate one reporter he humiliates one
reporter every single day and yesterday
that reporter was a young man who asked
about how this is all affecting the
price of oil and what our energy
response is going to be to this so the
kid barely gets his question out before
President Trump corners him and asks him
a simple question a question
unfortunately that he couldn't answer
what's the price of oil hey today I was
yeah today I was wondering if you know
where's the price give me the press how
can you ask a question we don't know the
price oh so brutal that is so
humiliating
I don't even know I don't know who that
reporter is he might be a perfectly nice
guy he might have just been having a bad
day and he he made the unlucky mistake
of not preparing for that one part of
the question Trump has got to keep this
up this was great
because look I don't again I don't want
to be unfair to this reporter if he
might have just not looked up the number
beforehand he should have known if he
says I want to I was just checking on
oil and I want to ask you about oil and
Trump said okay well what's the price
it's pretty important information if you
want me to give you my answer on oil and
he says I don't know he's got to keep
the reporters on their toes first it
puts the reporters on the defensive and
it discourages unfair questions if the
reporters know that he's gonna grill
them then they're not gonna be so loose
with their questions you know it's
actually the same justification that we
have for having the reporters in the
first place we have reporters ask tough
questions so that we keep the
politicians on their toes but the
politicians need to be tough too
otherwise the reporters are gonna take
advantage that's the first reason second
reason is it shows to everybody out here
that contrary to the media narrative
President Trump actually knows a lot
more about what's going on then all
these media people who are condescending
to him and who are criticizing him and
who are mocking him what this shows when
it's just him and the reporters
unvarnished live TV it shows that Trump
knows a lot more than our self-appointed
elites in the mainstream media do you
you don't get that when you just watch
prerecorded left-wing cable news you
don't get that when you just read the
New York Times but live unvarnished on
TV you do see that and it's why it's
important for Donald Trump to humiliate
these reporters on occasion he's got to
do it fairly and this was a fair way to
do it but the press comes out there
every day and tries to unfairly
humiliate Trump and so Trump's got to
give it back to them and then the people
can decide there was some news that came
out of the briefing yesterday beyond dr.
Burks who said that we're gonna be
recording these these deaths in a way
that's going to compromise our data
beyond these other questions that came
up the most important news the president
Trump broke is that the United States is
planning on defunding the World Health
Organization the
w-h-o that's the world health
organization receives vast amounts of
money from the United States and we pay
for a majority or biggest portion of
their money and they actually criticized
and disagreed with my travel ban at the
time I did it and they were wrong
they've been wrong about a lot of things
and then a lot of information early and
they didn't wanted a very they seem to
be very China centric and we have to
look into that so we're going to look
into it we pay for we give a majority of
the money that they get they called it
wrong they call it wrong they really
they missed the call they could have
called it months earlier they would have
known and they should have known and
they probably didn't know so we'll be
looking into that very carefully and
we're gonna put a hold on money spent to
the w-h-o we're gonna put a very
powerful hold on it and we're gonna see
love that great idea should have done it
a long time ago the World Health
Organization the w-h-o is a mouthpiece
for the Chinese Communist government and
has been for some time I mean I mean I
mean this is not a conspiracy this is
you can you can look exactly to the
dates when they appointed their own
Lackey to run the w-h-o guy who runs the
w-h-o is a politician it's a communist
politician that was specifically
requested by the Chinese government and
as payback for that this guy has been
carrying water for them totally ignored
the warning signs of the pandemic didn't
even send experts over there until
February
despite the outbreak happening in China
but possibly as early as October and who
knows we might find out it was even
earlier than that a w-h-o actually the
most intense passionate campaign they've
waged during this whole pandemic was to
get President Trump and other people to
stop calling it the Chinese coronavirus
because they wanted to hide China's
culpability in all of this an egregious
organisation that has not only failed
but has really carried propaganda for
some of the worst people on earth and
they shouldn't get a penny of our money
speaking of China China infiltrated
White House press briefing a reporter
this was not yesterday's briefing but
day before a reporter kept kept
pestering Trump with questions about
China and all the good that China's
doing and how China's helping out and
why won't he keep working with China and
so president Trump just flat-out ask
this person said what outlet are you
with are you with an outlet that is with
the Chinese government and Trump was
absolutely pilloried for this in the
mainstream media as a racist as a
xenophobe as a bigot all the usual stuff
here's the exchange I hope they gotta
honor the deal working for China work
with China are you within this paper who
you with China is it all by China by the
state okay okay okay good you can hear
in Trump's voice he doesn't quite
believe it so the press they say how
racist just because this woman looks
Chinese and and sounds Chinese you're
asking if she's working for the Chinese
government and of course that's not why
he was asking he was asking because sure
sounded like she was she was asking
questions that were nice to China right
I don't think he was doing it because I
thought she looked or sounded I think he
was doing it not primarily at lycée he
was doing it primarily because she was
asking questions that any Chinese
propagandist would ask so then she says
no I'm with an independent outlet the
Phoenix so and you google that outlet
and it turns out she lied actually she
is working for the Chinese government
actually the Chinese government owns a
lot of that news operation and it turns
out Donald Trump was totally right and
he was right to ask the question he was
right in his suspicions and a Chinese
propagandist infiltrated the White House
press briefing which look these things
happen
governments do use the press subversive
left-wing governments use the press I
mean you know our own subversive
left-wing politicians use the press here
even here in the United States so that
this kind of thing happens before Trump
was right about this this is something
we've got to watch and the knee-jerk
reaction to say that everything Trump
does is wrong and bigoted and terrible
four members of our own press is a
pretty egregious thing in the face of a
pandemic that was caused by the Chinese
government and yet they're defending the
Chinese propagandists in the briefing
room so president Trump talked about a
few other things in these briefings he
he mentioned yesterday that he spoke to
Joe Biden and one thing I really liked
about this is Joe Biden wanted to have a
phone call with Trump and I said on the
show a few days ago I liked how Trump
handled it he said okay I love him I
love a phone call it wasn't I can't talk
to him what can he offer me it wasn't
hostile it wasn't he was very gracious
about he said yeah I'll take a phone
call then they had the phone call he was
asked how the phone call was he said he
I was fine it was nice I had a nice call
for about 15 minutes that was that
brushes it off and moves on it keeps him
so elevated and it keeps Joe looking so
small because we were all wondering what
what's Joe going to offer on this phone
call Joe can't remember his own name
what's he gonna do he's gonna solve the
pandemic the Trump is already doing a
pretty good job of solving and so I
think Trump intuited that too he said
okay what do you got Joe Joe had nothing
so the call was absolutely nothing
actually we just found out what Joe's
got because well Trump is solving this
unprecedented global pandemic or a
certainly unprecedented in recent memory
yes I guess the Spanish flu was pretty
bad too but you're not allowed to
compare this to the flu anyway so let's
call it unprecedented well while
President Trump is doing that Joe Biden
is quarantined at home for getting his
own name and putting out a podcast
because it's the only medium that he can
work in right it's a medium where he can
have his voice sped up but he can be
edited I've actually I think they've
slowed down the edit since I pointed out
how ridiculous it sounded so I'll take a
little bit of credit for that but
they've slowed it down just a little bit
but they can clean him up they can take
out all the weird stuff and yet the best
that Joe Biden can muster this is the
actual trailer put out by the Biden
campaign the best he can muster in this
time of crisis is to talk about how much
he loves Fig Newton cookies our Fig
Newtons your favorites now well they're
among the favorite you know why they're
small and I can sneak him I know that
you can buy little packs of them and I
get them on the on the planes when I fly
back and forth
and but the thing that is the thing that
everybody makes fun of me that when in
doubt I have a peanut butter jelly
sandwich but I learned everybody was
making fun of that and I found out John
Kerry has the same addiction peanut
butter and jelly sandwich jelly sandwich
is always good my daughter and I enjoyed
it when you were in Michigan and you
shared your Fig Newtons little mess oh
that's right I had some and I remember
that oh you always have a little pack
some of with me this is riveting stuff
I'm sorry I'm just on the edge of my
seat right now I don't even know how I
can go on with the show after that
bombshell that Joe Biden likes not only
Fig Newton cookies but also peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches I didn't
clip that out that's the trailer that
the Biden campaign used that's their
best stuff I don't think that we want
that guy to become the president I don't
think that we want to give that guy a
lot of power I don't think that we need
to tolerate the largest political power
grab in our lifetimes if the man who's
gonna wield that power barely knows what
planet he's on and the most important
and incisive commentary he can muster is
his favorite cookie not a good place to
be fortunately President Trump is doing
a good job I hope he continues to do a
good job and pushes that timeline of
reopening up not at the absolutely
unacceptable 18 months but even closer
not eight weeks not even four weeks we
need to get this thing going again we've
seen a lot of promise on the medical
front on the modeling front as those
alarmist models have fallen apart we
need to get moving again it's it's time
to do that we can weather this storm the
president might even come out of this
looking better but at time is running
out and you don't want to be in a
situation where we're stuck with with
president Fig Newton okay that's our
show
I'm Michael knows this the Michael no
show get a lot more will do it all
tomorrow see them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
nikka Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20/20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there